salud en directo américa de francia 24
ya está marina sardiña con nosotros en
el estudio marina para hablar como lo
estábamos avanzando del aborto en
colombia porque hace unos días se
cumplieron ya los 6 meses desde que la
corte constitucional colombiana sacará
el código penal la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta la semana
24 de la gestación que ha pasado
entonces en este medio año de aborto
legal en el país marina buenos días raúl
si esto fue un triunfo de la lucha
feminista en materia de derechos
sexuales y reproductivos para las
mujeres niñas adolescentes y personas
gestantes del país de colombia y como
decías el pasado 21 de febrero la corte
constitucional votó a favor de
despenalizar el aborto en el país hasta
la semana 24 de gestación
recordemos que el aborto ya era legal en
colombia dentro de un sistema de tres
causales que continúa operando después
de la semana 24 colombia se convirtió
así en el país de américa latina con la
normativa más progresista de la región y
del mundo y esto generó fuertes
polémicas y críticas entre los sectores
conservadores como los datos de las
organizaciones que ayudan a las mujeres
a acceder a la ive el 92 por ciento de
las interrupciones pasan antes de la
semana 12 de embarazo el 7 por ciento
entre la semana 13 y la 20 y sólo el 0
95% después de la semana 20 de gestación
pese a todo esto los obstáculos para
acceder a un aborto seguro sigue
suponiendo un reto para toda la región y
para las mujeres en colombia se siguen
encontrando barreras dentro de las
instituciones sanitarias se estima que
se realizan 400 mil abortos clandestinos
cada año para evitar estos instituciones
pioneras en materia de derechos sexuales
como orienta me están realizando
campañas para llegar a llevar este
derecho a todos los territorios hablamos
con lady alba bermúdez ella es
coordinadora del nuevo proyecto de
orientarme que se llama justicia
reproductiva de la organización como
decíamos orientarme bienvenida a
france24 y gracias por estar con
nosotros
ley de más de 100 días desde la
despenalización del aborto en colombia
cuéntanos cómo se está implementando o
cómo va la implementación
nuevo marco legal
bueno muy buenos días
marina estamos en deuda todavía ha sido
un proceso lento creo que estamos en
camino hacia la regularización pero
esperamos pues intervención desde las
entidades regulatorias de este proceso
para que se haga realidad todavía hay
barreras bien importantes en frente a
esta implementación
lady las saludos gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana en directo américa
de france 24 hablando también de lo que
pues estaba haciendo un abreboca en su
respuesta cuáles han sido las
principales barreras que se han
encontrado las mujeres niñas de
adolescentes y personas estantes para
este acceso a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo de la despenalización del
aborto especialmente en zonas rurales no
como es la situación allí
bueno resumamos las un poco y es empieza
por el desconocimiento de las ips y las
ips es frente a la nueva sentencia de
aborto legal
no se reconoce la obligatoriedad de la
inmediatez del fallo ni la actualización
de las rutas de atención hay exigencia
de requisitos innecesarios para la
práctica del aborto legal dentro de las
24 semanas
también hay entrega de información
errónea a la población y digamos que la
falta de conectividad pues dejada sin
información también autónoma a las
mujeres de zonas rurales y la presencia
de la violencia obstétrica para las
mujeres que deciden una interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo y la falta de
conocimiento en general del marco
normativo legal por diferentes actores
son en resumen como las principales
barreras para la población rural quiero
hacer énfasis y es que puesto como todo
llega tarde a los pueblos
dispersos a las comunidades los
territorios entonces la regulación hace
falta para tener exigibilidad en estos
territorios pero además también la falta
de conectividad la falta de información
inmediata a la falta de pedagogía de
comunicación de procesos educativos y de
promoción que permitan a la población
empoderarse de sus derechos también y
hacerlos realidad leidy y que grupo
poblacional o que población de mujeres
han encontrado que son los más
vulnerables que pasa por ejemplo con las
mujeres migrantes qué pasa con la
población lgtb de más cuéntanos un poco
sobre ello bueno nosotros justamente
dentro del proyecto hemos priorizado a
algunos grupos como son las mujeres
migrantes pues como sabemos la falta de
afiliación en salud
pues les dificulta entrar por un sistema
de salud público y algunos hospitales y
en estableció ruta de atención por
urgencia pero no es la práctica común
donde esta es la posibilidad que
tendrían ellas las mujeres rurales que
no tienen el servicio disponible en sus
territorios les toca caminar o pagar
mucho en transporte para llegar hasta el
primer lugar donde pueden recibir una
atención
los grupos el eje vete y pumas donde
sabemos que hay barreras por la falta de
inclusión a la diversidad en los
programas por el estigma que a veces
tienen los prestadores de salud entonces
esto se transfiere también a la
generalidad de los procesos de atención
de salud pero en particular también a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo por
el estigma frente a las prácticas de
como las personas viven su sexualidad y
cómo ejercen estas decisiones
para nosotros en este grupo hemos
priorizado las mujeres jóvenes las
mujeres rurales también las mujeres
migrantes porque sabemos la situación de
violencia de género de violencias
sexuales que viven en su proceso
migratorio y muchas veces esos embarazos
de esa violencia
lady gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en este espacio de salud de
directo américa de france a 24 también
marinas gracias por acompañarnos
estábamos conversando con lady alba
bermúdez subdirectora de programas de
salud reproductiva de la organización
oriéntame